- Where's your hand?
- I wish I could high five you.
Wait can you?
OK, wait, do it again.
- Yay.
(lighthearted music)
- I love nuggets
- Chicken nuggets, are
like a passion for sure.
- Whenever I'm super drunk
and I go to McDonald's
I get like 20 chicken nuggets
and I eat most of them.
- A good nugget has to have a good
breading to nugget ratio.
- Crispy on the outside,
but tender on the inside.
- This is 100% McDonald's, I
can just tell by the shape.
- Oh, juicy.
- Oh, this is from Burger King.
- It's a little bland.
- This is from Wendy's.
- How crunchy,
this is a sculpture of sorts.
- Oh, what is this?
- Oh, OK, interesting shape.
- You could chip a tooth on this thing.
- Meaty.
- I feel like it smells like Popeyes.
So, I'm into it.
- This is a husky little nugget.
- Man, why is it so, like, soft?
- This one's gross.
(laughs)
- It doesn't really
taste really flavorful.
- Maybe it's like, like a 7-Eleven.
- This is McDonald's, I can tell.
- (laughs) You said this before.
- I know.
- You can tell 'cause
it tastes like rubber.
- It's like too moist,
it's like too moist.
Like, you're like, how is it so moist?
- That is a good nugget.
- It's McDonald's.
- Yeah, this is Ronald, definitely
my man Ronald, shout out.
- The chicken places know how to make
chicken nuggets better
than the burger places.
- The 7-Eleven one was
actually pretty good.
- Like the meat tasted, like, OK.
- 7-Eleven was definitely
the worst nugget.
The worst one.
It just, it was shaped weirdly,
it looked like Play-Doh,
that was just coming apart.
- I'm still a McDonald's or Wendy's guy.